This is an intermediate Git
course taught by Tobias Günther.
He'll help you move beyond Git
basics and improve your Git workflow.
Hello, Free Code Camp friends, my name is Tobias.
And I'm going to improve your Git knowledge today.
There are a lot of beginner tutorials
out there about version control with Git.
But I will help you understand the
concepts behind many things in git,
how to craft the perfect commit, how to
choose a branching strategy, or how merge
conflicts really work. So my goal is to give
you more confidence when you work with git,
and to get you a little bit closer
to becoming an advanced Git user.
Before we start a huge shout out to the Free
Code Camp team, thank you so much for being on
this mission of teaching people how to code. And
thanks for letting me contribute a little bit.
A couple of words about my own background, I'm
part of the team behind tower, and tower is a
git desktop GUI. for Mac and Windows, we've been
around for more than 10 years now, and helped over
100,000 developers and designers well work more
easily with git, become more productive with git,
and make fewer mistakes. For today's session,
you don't need to have tower installed,
you can follow along on the command line,
no problem. Alright, let's get started.
So let's talk a bit about how to create the
perfect commit. So the first part is to add the
right changes, right. And the second part is to
compose a good commit message. So let's start by,
let's start by adding changes to the
commit. So our goal here is to create
a commit that makes sense one that only
includes changes from a single topic.
And in contrast to the easy way when we
sometimes just cram all of our current
local changes into the next commit. So this
is the bad thing we should not do. But being
selective and carefully deciding what should
go into the next commit is really important.
This is a better way of how a better commit could
look like because it separates different topics.
On the other hand, the bigger a commit gets. And
the more topics that are mixed into the commit,
the harder it gets to understand both for your
colleagues and for yourself in the future. So
Git staging area concept is really helpful in this
context, it allows you to select specific files,
or even parts of those files for the next commit.
So this is what the staging area can do for you,
you can really select individual files for one,
commit, and even parts of files for one commit
and leave others for future commit. So let's take
a look at a practical example. And over the last
few hours, or maybe even days, we've created
a bunch of changes, let's say git status here.
But let's say that not all of those are
about the same topic. So let's stick to
that golden rule of version control to
only combine changes from the same topic
in a single commit. And you probably already know
that to include a specific file, we can simply
type, git add and the name of the file. So let's
add that CSS file here. And voila, and let's take
a closer look at another file index HTML and see
what changes it currently contains. So we can
use git diff for that. And we can see that there
are two parts or chunks of changes at the moment.
And let's say that the first one belongs to the
next commits topic, but not the second one. So
let's just add the first part to the staging
area, we can do that. Let me just exit the
output here. We can do that with the git add git
add dash p flag. P brings us down to the patch
level, we want to decide on the patch level what
to include and what not. And we want to do that
with index HTML. So now Git steps through every
every single chunk of changes with us. And it
asks us a simple question. Do we want to add
this chunk or hunk to the staging area or not?
Don't worry about all the other possible answers
you can give in that situation. I don't know them.
And I want to sleep at night for us. A simple
why for Yes, or n for no is sufficient. So let's
say this one is actually the topic that we want to
commit. So let's say yes, we want to include that.
And, and for the second one, this is not the
same topic. So let's leave that out of the
staging area for the moment. So if we now take
another look at git status, we can see that
parts of index HTML will be included in the next
commit changes to be committed, and other parts
will be left for a future commit. Again, so index
HTML is listed twice, awesome. crafting a commit
like this in a very granular way, will help you
create a very valuable commit history, one that
is easy to read and to understand. And this is
crucial if you want to stay on top of things.
Now let's talk about the second part of creating
that perfect commit. And that is providing great
commit message. We'll start with the subject line.
So of course, conventions are different between
teams. But generally, the advice is to write
something very concise, less than 80 characters if
possible. And the subject should be a very brief
summary of what happened. And here's a little
hint, if you have trouble writing something short
and concise, then this might be an indication that
you've put too many different topics into that
commit, right. So let's go to the command line.
And if I now type, so I have a couple of
changes against stage for the next commit.
If I type git commit, I will get an editor
window where I can enter a commit message.
And we'll write something simple
ad capture for email signup.
If we add an empty line after the subject, get
knows we are writing the body of the message and
has room for a much more detailed explanation. So
here are a couple of questions you might want to
answer with your commit message body this
year, what's now different than before,
what's the reason for the change? And is there
anything to watch out for or anything particularly
remarkable about that commit. So I'll write my
version of that in the text editor here. And
voila, so let's save and close
this. And the commit is done.
Let's take a quick look at git log, and we can
see Okay, so this is the last commit we just did.
This is the subject, and this is the
body of the message. So by answering
these questions you're doing your colleagues
and your future self a huge favor, because
it helps to understand what exactly happened
in this revision, and what to watch out for.
Let's talk a bit about branching strategies.
This is an important topic because Git leaves it
completely up to you how you want to work with
branches. It only provides the tool, but you
and your team are responsible for using it in the
optimal way. And this brings us to our first topic
conventions. If you work in a team, you need to
come up with a clear convention on how to how
you want to work with branches. And you need to
write this down somewhere where it's accessible to
everyone. Why your team needs a written convention
you ask because Git allows you to create branches,
but it doesn't tell you how to use, you need
a written best practice of how to work or how
work is ideally structured in your team to avoid
mistakes and collisions. And this highly depends
on your team and team size on your project, and
how you handle releases of your software. last not
least it helps to onboard new team members. When
new people join your team, you can point them to
your documented will convention and will quickly
understand how branches are handled in your team.
When you think about how you want to work
with branches, you automatically think
about how you integrate changes and structure
releases. These topics are tightly connected.
To help you better understand your
options. Let's simplify a little bit.
I'll show you how to extreme versions
of how you could design your branching
workflows. And the motto of the first one is
always be integrating mainline development.
Always integrate your own work with the
work of the team. That's the motto here.
And this is how it could look. In this
example we only have a single branch
where everyone contributes their commits. So
this is a really simple For example, I doubt
that any team in the real world would have such
simple branching structure. But for illustration,
this extreme simplified example helps us
understand the advantages and disadvantages
of this model. So in an always be integrating
model, you have very few branches. And this makes
it easier to keep track of things in your project.
Of course, also commits in this model must be
relatively small. This is a natural requirement
because you cannot risk big bloated commits
in such an environment where things are
constantly integrated into production code.
And this also means that you must have a high
quality testing environment setup. Again,
the premise in this model is that code is
integrated very quickly into your main line
your production code. And this means that testing
and QA standards in your team must be top notch.
If you don't have this, this model will not
work for you. The other end of the spectrum
is when multiple different types of branches
enter the stage. So here branches are used
to fill to fulfill different jobs. New features
and experiments are kept in their own branches.
releases can be planned and managed it managed
in their own branches. And even different states
in your development flow, like production
develop, can be represented by branches.
Remember that this all depends on the needs
and requirements of your team and project,
it's hard to say that one approach is better
than the other. And although a model like
this one seems complicated, it's mostly a
matter of practice and getting used to it.
And as I already said, in reality, most teams
are working somewhere in between these extremes.
Now let's look closer at two main types
of branches and how they are used.
These two types of branches are long
running and short lived branches.
So the distinction between a long
running and a short lived branch
is one of the broadest you can make and a
very helpful one. So let's start about talking
about the long running branches first. Every
Git repository contains at least one long
running branch typically something called main or
master. But there might be also other long running
branches in your project something like develop
or production or staging. For example, these
branches all have something in common they exist
throughout the complete lifecycle of the project.
I've already mentioned one typical example of
such a long running branch. Every project has a
mainline branch like master or main. And another
type of long running branches are so called
integration branches, often named develop or
staging. Typically, these branches represent
states in a project release or deployment process.
If your code moves through different states,
for example, from development to staging to
production, it makes a lot of sense to mirror the
structure in your branches to. And finally, many
teams have a convention connected to long running
branches. Typically commits are never directly
added to these branches. commits should only make
it to the long running branch through integration.
In other words, through a merge or rebase.
There are a couple of reasons for such a rule.
One has to do with quality. You don't want to
add untested and reviewed code to your production
environment as an example. And that's why code
should go through different states tests and
reviews before finally arrives on production.
Another reason might be release bundling and
scheduling, you might want to release new code
in batches maybe even thoroughly scheduled.
And without such a rule. When code is directly
committed to long running branches like main,
keeping an eye on what's released becomes pretty
difficult. Now the other type of branches are
short lived branches. And in contrast to long
running branches, they are created for certain
purposes, and then deleted after they have been
integrated. There are many different reasons
to create short live branches. For example,
when you start working on a new feature, a bug
fix or refactor refactoring or an experiment. And
typically a short lived branch will be based on a
long running branch. For example, when you start
a new feature, you might base that new feature
on your long running main branch for example,
and after making some commits and finishing
your work, you probably want to re integrate it
back into main. And after you've safely merged or
rebased it your feature branch can be deleted. And
I've already said that branching strategies
will be different for each team and project.
It highly depends on your preferences
or team size or type of project.
But I'd like to give you a glimpse into two
pretty popular branching strategies, and take both
of them as inspiration for your own individual
branching strategy. Let's start with GitHub flow.
GitHub advocates a workflow that's extremely
lean and simple. It only has a single long
running branch, the default main branch, and
anything you're actively working on is done in
a separate branch, a short left branch, no matter
if that's a feature a bug fix, or a factoring.
So this is a very simple, very lean setup. Another
very popular model is called Git flow. And this
offers a bit more structure but also more rules to
follow. So the main branch is a reflection of the
current production state. The other long running
branch is typically typically called develop
in any feature branches start from
this one, and will be merged back
into it. Develop is also the starting point
for any new releases, you would open a new
release branch, do your testing commit
any bug fixes to that release branch.
And once you're confident that it's ready
for production, you merge it back into
main, you would then add a tag for that release,
commit on Main, and close the release branch.
As you can see, good flow defines quite a
couple of tasks and steps in the process.
In tower, the good desktop GUI that we make,
we support users by offering these tasks as
shortcuts in the app. And that way I can show
you here, so you have all of the most important
actions that Git flow brings to you. So you
don't have to remember all of the bits and
pieces and what you have to do and what comes
next, that makeup, these different steps.
So if you ask different teams, how they are using
branches, you will get many different answers.
There is no perfect branching model that everyone
should adopt. It's more about understanding your
project, your release workflow and your team,
and then modeling a branching workflow that
supports you in the best way possible. Let's talk
about pull requests. First of all, you need to
understand that pull requests are not a core good
feature. There are provided by your Git hosting
platform, which means they work and look a little
bit differently on GitHub, git lab, Bitbucket,
Azure DevOps, or whatever you're using. But the
basic principles and ideas are always the same.
Let's start by talking about why you would
want to use pull requests at all. In essence,
they are a way to communicate about code and
review it. The Perfect example is when you've
finished working on a feature, without a pull
request, you'd simply merge your code into main
master or some other branch. And in some cases,
this might be totally fine. But especially when
your changes are a bit more complex or a bit
more important, you might want to have a second
pair of eyes look over your code. And this
is exactly what pull requests were made for.
With pull requests, you can invite other people
to review your work and give you feedback.
And after some conversation about the code,
your reviewer might approve the pull request and
merge it into another branch. Apart from this,
there's another important use case for pull
requests. It's a way to contribute to code to
repositories, which you don't have right access
to think of a popular open source repository, you
might have an idea for improving something, but
you're not one of the main contributors and you're
not allowed to push commits to their repository.
This is another use case for pull requests. And we
also have to talk about forks in this connection
of fork is your personal copy of a git repository.
And going back to our open source example,
you can fork the original repository.
make changes in your forked version and
open a pull request to include those
changes into the original repository.
And one of the main contributors can then review
your changes and decide to include them or not.
I already mentioned it. Every good platform has
its own design and understanding of how pull
requests should work. And they look a little
bit different on GitHub, git lab Bitbucket or
Azure DevOps, or whatever you're using. So here
is an example we'll use the GitHub interface.
For this test case, let's use the Ruby on
Rails open source repository and Let's see.
Alright, so here we are on GitHub on the Ruby
on Rails main repository. And in the top right,
I can fork this repository, so I can create
my own personal version of the repository.
And it's code base. And again, a reminder
about why we're doing this, I don't have
access to push code into Ruby on Rails, into the
Ruby on Rails repository. And for good reasons,
of course, because I'm not a Ruby on Rails Pro.
But in my own fork repository, I can make changes,
I can make whatever changes I want. So I just
did that I forked the repository. And I can now
simply clone that I'll get the clone URL, and then
on the command line, git clone and remote URL.
And we will, in a second, when
this has finished cloning,
we will create a branch and make some changes. So
this is also important to understand pull requests
are always based on branches,
not on individual commits.
So we're creating a new branch which we later
request to be included. And let's ogburn
let's go into rails, and open this in my editor.
And I'll just create a brief branch git branch
test and git checkout test. Alright,
so I now am on a new branch and can
make a silly little change, let's change
something in the readme file. This is a,
an awesome web application framework, close
this. Alright, let's take a look at our changes.
git add README and git commit dash m silly
little change. So we now have made some small
changes on a separate branch, and we can push that
branch to our own remote repository, our fork,
so git push set upstream origin tests test. And
once this is available, okay, so this has worked.
So we have now created the changes that we can
request to be included. Once I've pushed
them to my remote repository on GitHub,
I can take another look at the repository
in the browser and see what happened.
And voila, GitHub has noticed that I just pushed
something here. And since it's a fork of forked
repository, GitHub detected my changes, and
automatically asks me if I want to create a pull
request with those changes. Because in a forked
environment, this is mostly what you want to do.
And if I do, I can propose which branch they
should be integrated in. So I'll start the
pull request process here. So at the moment, I'm
proposing to integrate my changes from my little
branch here in the fork back into the main branch
in Rails, and let's say that is okay. And I can
add some comment. And I could then create the
pull request and the maintainer of the original
repository would then be notified, and they can
review my changes, and possibly integrate them.
Merge conflicts, nobody likes them,
but they are a fact of life when you're
working with Git. And in most cases, they
are not as tragic as we often think. Oh,
we'll talk about when they happen, what
they actually are and how to solve them.
Alright, so the name already says it. Merge.
Conflicts can occur when you integrate when your
merge changes from a different source. But keep
in mind that integration is not limited to only
merging branches. Conflicts can also happen when
rebasing interactive rebasing when performing a
cherry pick or a pull, or even when reapplying
a stash, and all of these actions performed
some kind of integration and that's when merge,
conflicts can happen. Of course, these actions
don't result in a merge conflict every time
Thank God. But when exactly do conflicts occur,
actually gets merging capabilities are one of its
greatest features and advantages. Merging branches
works effortlessly most of the time, because Git
is usually able to figure things out on its own.
But there are situations where contradictory
changes were made. And that's when technology
simply cannot decide what's right or wrong.
These situations require a decision from a human.
The true classic is when the exact
same line of code was changed into
commits on two different branches. Git has
no way of knowing which change you prefer.
There are some other similar situations
that are a little bit less common,
for example, when a file was modified
in one branch and deleted in another.
But the same, but the problem is always the
same changes contradict when you're working
with a desktop GUI, like tower forget, that
can make things easier, especially because it's
just more visual, I can select things here. And
this helps me understand what actually happens,
I can see these two changes conflict and I
can select one or both or just this year and
solve the conflict pretty easily. How do
you know when a conflict has occurred?
Don't worry about that get will tell you very
clearly, when a conflict has happened. First,
it will let you know immediately in the
situation, for example, when a merge or rebase
fails with a conflict. So let's try this
out. Actually, we have something here, let's
provoke a merge conflict. And I'll just try
to merge in developer to my main branch.
And voila, automatically I can see something is
wrong here. Conflict conflict conflict, automatic
merge failed. So you can see that when I tried
to perform the merge, I ran into conflict and get
tells me instantaneously about the problem. But
even while even if I had overlooked these warning
messages, I would find out about the conflict
the next time I run git status. So let's do that.
And pretty quickly, you have this unmerged path
category in the status here. So in other words,
don't worry about not noticing, merge conflicts
get makes sure you can't overlook them.
All right, um, though you
can't ignore a merge conflict,
you really have to deal with it
before you can continue your work.
Dealing with a merge conflict doesn't necessarily
mean you have to resolve it, you can also undo
it. And this is sometimes very helpful. So keep
this in mind always, you can always undo a merge
conflict and return to the state before. And
this is true even when you've already started
resolving some of the conflicted files and you
notice Oh god, I'm, I'm on the wrong track here.
Even then, when you find yourself in a
dead end, you can still undo the merge.
And some commands come with an abort option that
lets you do exactly that. So the most prominent
examples are Git merge, Uber abort, and Git rebase
abort. So in our example, here, when I find why
I don't have the time to deal with this right
now, or I've resolved something the wrong way,
I can always type Git merge dash dash abort here,
and get status shows me I'm back to normal again.
So this should give you the confidence that you
really cannot mess up, you can always aboard,
return to clean state and try again start
over. So let's see what a conflict really
looks like under the hood, we will
demystify those little buggers. And,
at the same time, help you lose respect for
them and gain a little bit of confidence.
So as an example, let's look at the contents
of one of the conflict files. I'll provoke that
merge conflict once again, and I can see that
in my index HTML file, I have a conflict. So
let's take a look at that. And
Nope, not this one. But this one.
So get was kind enough to mark the problematic
areas in the file. So they're surrounded by these
symbols here. This is the start and this is the
end of the problem area. So the content that
came that comes after the first marker, originally
originates from our current working branch, then
aligned with some equal lines equal signs,
separates the two conflicting changes. And
finally, this year came from the other branch
that's displayed as well. So in this case,
it's pretty simple. In the develop branch
where I made some changes, I deleted this
list item, these list items, and in my head
branch, I changed them. So Git is unsure,
did you want to change them? Like Like
this? Or did you want to delete them?
Like here? And I have to tell git,
what's correct and what's not.
Okay, so how can you solve a conflict, solving
the conflict is actually pretty simple, we need
to clean up these lines. And after we finish, the
file should look exactly as we want it to look.
So it might be necessary to talk to the teammate
who wrote the other changes and decide which code
is actually correct, maybe it's ours, maybe it's
theirs, maybe it's a mixture between the two.
And this process of cleaning up the file, making
sure it contains the what we actually want. This
doesn't have to involve any magic, you can do this
simply by opening your text editor or ID and make
some changes. Sometimes, though, you'll find that
this is not the most efficient way, that's when
dedicated tools can save you a little bit time and
effort. So on the one hand, there are good desktop
gooeys. Some of the graphical user interfaces for
good can be helpful when solving conflicts, you've
already seen one. So this is tower where you could
where you can see what happened in the conflict.
And this visualizes the problem. And on the
other hand, there are dedicated merge tools.
For more complicated conflicts can be great to
have a dedicated different merge tool at hand,
you can configure a tool of choice using the Git
config command. And then in case of a conflict,
you can simply type Git merge tool and have it
open the conflict, I have a kaleidoscope app
installed on my Mac. So let's just try this Git
merge tool. I configured that. So the first one,
as you can see is a pretty easy one or the
second one here, error HTML was deleted. So
I don't need to see that I just need to decide,
do I want to keep it or do I want to delete it.
So I'll stick with the deletion. And for the
second one, there's really content in the file,
where it makes sense to open that merge tool
that I configured, I can see, well, this is
the the change that I made. And this is the change
that came from another person or from a different
branch. And what do I want to look like and what
I wanted to look like I can choose these changes,
or these year or I can make my own changes here.
So after cleaning up the file, either manually
or in a desktop, do your GUI or merge tool, we
have to commit this like any other change. So I
can save it here and say this is resolved. And
if I type git status, I can see these changes
would be committed, I've made some changes here
in index HTML, this here is just a safety copy,
you can configure that also to happen. So you
can always return to the to the original file.
But I would actually just commit this
here. And simply by committing the resolved
files, I signal to get that conflict is
completed. And I can go on with my work.
Most developers understand that it's
important to use branches in git,
because having separate containers
for your work is incredibly helpful.
Let's talk a bit about integrating branches
about getting your new code back into an existing
branch. There are different ways to do this, and
the two most common ones are merge and rebase.
Let's start by talking about
merge and how it actually works.
When Git performs a merge, it looks for three
commits. First the common ancestor commit.
If you follow the history of two branches in a
project, they always have at least one commit in
common. At this point, both branches had the same
content. And after that they evolve differently.
The other interesting commits are
the end points of each branch.
Remember that the goal of an integration is
to combine the current states of two branches.
So the latest revisions are of course
important. Combining these three commits,
will perform the integration that we're aiming
for. I've chosen a very simple example case
here because one of the two branches are
a branch a here, it didn't receive any new
commits after the branching happened. So its
latest commit is also the common ancestor.
In this case, the integration is dead simple
good can just add all the new commits from
branch B on top of the common ancestor
commit. And and get the simplest form
of integration is called a fast forward merge.
Both branches then share the exact same history.
In most most cases, however, both branches
move forward differently, of course.
And to make an integration, good,
we'll have to create a new commit
that contains the differences between them.
And this is what we call a merge commit.
Normally, a commit is carefully created by a
human being at some meaningful unit that wraps
only related changes in the commit message
provides context and notes. Now, a merge
commit is a bit different. It's not created by a
developer, it gets created automatically by Git.
And it also does not wrap a set of related
changes. Its purpose is to connect two
branches just like a knot. If you want to
understand a merge operation after the fact,
you need to take a look at the history of
both branches and their commit history.
Now let's talk about rebase. But before we
start, let me emphasize something rebase is
not better or worse than merge. Most importantly,
it's different. You can live a happy, good life
just using merge. But rebase has its pros and
cons. So knowing what it does, and when it could
be helpful is nice. Alright, remember that we
just talked about the automatic merge commit,
some people would prefer to go without these,
they want the project history to look like a
straight line, without any science that it had
been split into multiple branches at some point,
even after branches have been integrated. And
this is what happens with rebase. Let's walk
through a rebase operations step by step. The
scenario is the same as in the previous example,
we want to integrate changes from branch
B into branch a. But now by using rebase.
The actual Git command to start this is
really simple. It's just Git rebase and
the branch. Similar to Git merge, we just
tell git, which branch we want to integrate.
But let's take a look behind the scenes.
First, git will remove all commits on branch
a that happened after the common ancestor commit.
But don't worry, will not throw them away,
you can think of those commits as being
parked as saved somewhere temporarily.
Then get applies to new commits from branch B.
And at this point temporarily, both branches
look exactly the same. But in the final step,
those parked commits need to be included,
the new commits from branch a, they're positioned
on top of the integrated commits from branch B,
they are rebased, as you can see, and the result
looks like development had happened in a straight
line, there is no merge commit that contains all
the combined changes, we preserve the original
commit structure. There's one more thing an
important thing to understand about rebase
it rewrites commit history. So take a close look
at this last diagram here. Commit c three has an
asterisk symbol, it has the same contents as C
three, but it's effectively a different commit.
Because it now has a new parent before the rebase.
See, one was its parent. And after the rebase,
it's C for which it was rebased onto a
commit has only a handful of important
properties like the author date change set and
who its parent commit is. and changing anything
any of this information, if effectively creates a
completely new commit and with a new commit hash.
So we writing history, like that is not
a problem for commits that haven't been
published or pushed yet. But if you're rewriting
commits that have already been pushed to a remote
repository, you might be in trouble. Because
another developer might have based their work
on the original c three commit, which is not here
anymore. So let's close this topic with a simple
rule. Do not rewrite commits, that you've already
pushed to a shared repository. tools like rebase,
you should only use them for cleaning up your
local commit history. For example, for a feature
branch that you've been working on for some time,
and before you integrate that back into a team
branch, then you're using re Based on that, that's
what these tools like in rebase were made for.
Alright, so much for today. Be sure to check out
my little advanced Git kit. It's completely free
of charge. It's a little collection of short
videos about a lot of advanced Git topics from
things like interactive rebase, all
the way to branching strategies,
merge conflicts, sub modules, what
have you. It's really helpful if you
want to become more productive with
Git and version control. And again,
it's free. More right? Have fun and see you
soon. Here on the Free Code Camp YouTube channel.